when people are in crisis especially I
will start with a question of sleep
and if you're sleeping we will get down
to work on working through the crisis
and if they're not sleeping I will get
down to work on figuring out how to help
them sleep so that we even have a chance
of getting them through and what I'll
say to parents is look it's not a
substitute for therapy but make sure
your kid is sleeping make sure your kid
is physically active make sure they're
eating well enough have them do
purposeful things put them in positions
where they're doing service or
activities these things don't take the
place of a really good clinician doing
really good work but they go very very
far often in both reducing mental health
concerns and certainly in helping to
prevent them